hello reject nation um Greg Elbe we're
gonna watch the trailer for The Walking
Dead Season eight I'm gonna hold my back
when I watch this trailer I can't do
that the head of Bob that [ __ ] does
anyway yeah it's my home on that
taeho evil shirt or there's no actual
product placement I just have a lot of
products anyway Kamikaze lodging Dead
Season a
I hope you got your [ __ ] in pants on you
should I hope you weren't
oh he is because you
[Laughter]
I love negan in doses gets a good cheese
for the trailer great
got horrible right impression oh snap
Killa wait for them walkers me looking
that guy's impressions hilarious Aaron
character
[Music]
[Music]
I mean I people should kill you
tricksters is gonna pay up damn Oh
when I first made it
jesus said my world can't get a whole
lot bigger
we found that world we found each other
that bigger world is ours by right those
who use and take until we end them to
human seed for what for being such a
cool dish ha ha ha I love that gag they
would be everything we've endured
everything we've risen above everything
we've become no matter what comes next
we've won we've already won
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man this trailer is an act other
times to perform physical the way you
need to correct you on that point we
need to keep our faith in each other if
we can hold on to that with everything
we might have the future is ours
the world is ours over your ears yeah
[Music]
trust the G
and on this day we begin to reshape this
work
[Music]
I don't know Dorf I'd say this is a loop
action and whoa
[Music]
Glenn Glenn Lane
[Music]
what the hell what was that Xion Xion
heaven is Rick God ah nipple chill man
so initial thought for years I've been
hearing people complain about the
walking dead not being that great of a
show keep going down in quality I didn't
agree with any of that until those
season seven the season seven I really
was disappointed and thought it became
the negan show for too much of it I
thought it was way too spread out and I
felt like the last episode could have
been an episode that came in way earlier
in this season and then you could have
progressed even further it was like a
lot of build-up to not that big of a
payoff in the end like we all knew it
was going that direction and then it
just took forever to get there this
trailer I thought it was interesting I
wasn't expecting a season 8 trailer to
be done like this because it's rather
upbeat it's fast paced it's quick edit
and it looks like it's having more fun
which I feel like it's just the trailer
I don't think that's the actual show
that'll be having more fun with it I
mean I like it if the Walking Dead could
pick up its pace not too much because I
was one of the best parts of the Walking
Dead is that it's a show that does take
its time however last season just was
wasting too much time all I really want
for this season is for it to be what I
thought season 7 was going to be which
is just this all-out war Rick and his
group and then you know everyone else on
his team versing the Savior's with
walkers in between it being an all-out
war lot of violence a lot of mayhem and
it looks like it's going to deliver on
that I don't know what the thing was
with Rick at the end I mean he has like
the kid
I think I know okay full disclosure I'm
never ready comics well I've read like a
few of the early graphic novel at the
beginning one when season seven did and
you know I would read a lot of articles
like you guys are inside Zurich Netcom
and it's just my theory I don't know
probably some research for putting this
in the video from what I remember in the
comics I think they beat me again
and negan breaks his legs people say
there's a time lapse after the war with
negan is done Rick had like a shaved
head and a big-ass beard and he has to
walk with a cane eating a broke his legs
that's probably what attending at the
show when it comes to its teasers and
trailers they can often throw stuff in
there that's like oh is this going to be
exactly like the comics and from my
understanding a lot of negan was ripped
directly from the comics so perhaps
they're honoring that and maybe this is
just some dream sequence in some way
because it's really shot like a dream
sequence even though the comics Rick
beats negan I feel like a lot of people
will be inquiring about that image and
it kind of feels like a spoiler if they
if that's what they're confirming it
doesn't make more interesting in a weird
way that is but anyway besides that that
ending that I'm sure a lot of people are
going to be getting hung up on what I
really just want for this season is for
it to just be an all-out war I don't
want Maury to be really humble to like
do you just kill and Carol you know I
want her to be killing I like not just
like going back on her did I want to
deal with that Maggie seems like she's
going to be more of a leader this season
the zekiel seems like he's going to be
kicking some serious ass I really hope
this isn't just a cool trailer and that
is act this is an accurate
representation of what season 8 is going
to be like because this is a lot more
along lines of what I wanted season 7 to
be like and if season 8 is accurately
being portrayed like this I'm sure I'll
be satisfied which will probably make
season 7 better yet season 7 will feel
like the major build up to what season 8
is longer manager Lincoln's on the show
I'll be around and that shot with Daryl
riding the motorcycle should be good
alright are you jack nation well you can
subscribe to the real rejects you son of
a [ __ ] become part of the reject nation
follow me at the greg alba
on instagram
and Twitter go check out our exclusive
perks and rewards at patreon.com slash
real rejects this year's Lucille
horrible impressions of Gregg 101